I cheated my way into college and this
is that story craziest story I've
actually ever heard about cheating was
my one of my friends he actually tried
to cheat on an AP test which I didn't do
because you know I'm smarter than that
his scores got canceled so I definitely
didn't want that happening to me the
person I was most afraid of getting
yelled at by if I got caught up was my
mom broke my mom is Nigerian she's all
about you know doing everything by the
book
everything the way it's supposed to be
if I had got caught enough cheating she
would have probably bought me a ticket
straight back to Nigeria but I swear I
swear she would have done it without
hesitation it started in the 12th grade
I was sort of known as a class clown I'd
always do get on the test but whenever
the teacher would ask me a question I
never be answerable my teacher would
always suspect me of cheating due to my
like high test scores but she could
never catch me in that act for a midterm
we took early in the year she separated
me away from the class due to my
distracted behavior which I guess makes
sense
on average I tend to do good on the test
you know getting A's and B's due to my
wizardry cheating skills of course and a
tightener relationship within all the
nerdy kids
well that midterm however I just barely
managed to scratch a c-minus and from
then on I'd known her suspicious of me
cheated probably girls she even changed
the seating arrangements in the class to
keep an eye on me fast-forward a couple
weeks the final test was coming up worth
over 65 percent of our grade I was
nervous I knew she was probably gonna
pull the same trick on me for the
midterm when she separated me away from
the class so I just planned ahead my
plan was to go to the review session
which was held two weeks before the
final exam I went to the review session
with nothing but hope honest he just
needed something to save me so I pulled
up to the session early about 15
students were there with the teacher all
going over the study guide the teacher
coincidentally had the study guys in the
far back of the room on her desk it was
just so happened to be where she kept
the answer keys with what would be test
a and test B but at that time I didn't
know that so I tried studying but after
a few hours went by I was just about
ready to call it quits I had to learn a
year's worth of math and physics
equations within a few days it was
pretty much impossible and all of a
sudden boom the teacher leaves the class
to take a bathroom break and I was free
to do whatever I had to do
I was already sitting towards the back
of the class near her desk I knew I had
to act quickly by any
some pieces test so I quickly stood up
and started scrambling through to review
guys on top of her desk while I was
really looking for the answer keys I was
scrambling and scrambling I was nervous
that she was gonna come back I was
looking over my shoulder I mean I was
just I was freaking out my hands were
shaking while I opened up the cabinet
and found big answers to both test and
test D I couldn't believe my eyes I
quickly pulled out my phone it took
pictures of both answer keys each one of
them had the answers to all 55 of the
test questions I completely ignored the
written response questions because
they're only worth about 25 percent of
the final grade and I could honestly get
a B or above without it but then grabbed
the random study guide went back to my
seat and acted like nothing happened I
managed to do this all under 30 seconds
fast forward a couple weeks and I
already have both ASU keys a and B
memorised like my ABCs I haven't made a
whole song about it a b c c c d BB a BB
BB i came to the test straight chillin
not worrying about what version of the
test she was gonna throw at me you know
so I walked into the room and I have my
backpack on have my earphones in oh no
just cruisin and the minute I walked in
she was just looking at me and I already
knew she was gonna try to put me
somewhere else they're trying to do
something to mess up my date and to my
surprise she had me sit it separately
from the rest of the students just like
she did on the midterm I walked in you
know no questions asked went to my seat
did what I had to do I got my test and
it was test I said okay right started
taking the test 30 minutes 20 minutes I
was done I ended up getting a b-plus and
there was no trace of suspicion
whatsoever I felt like a G and at the
end of the semester I ended up finishing
off with a 90% in the club I never
really felt guilty about cheating
because at the end of the day comes down
to this gotta work smarter not harder if
my kid ever got caught cheating I'd be
very disappointed I'll be disappointed
because I'd be like I've never got car
teen how could you come out of me and
get coach it in terms of getting into
college transfer papers and all that it
actually helped me a lot because ap
physics is like low key one of the
hardest courses to go through in high
school so I had gotten into UCLA I've
gone into UC Santa Barbara so now I'm in
college and I've unfortunately decided
to retire my cheating ways yeah I could
get but for life if I ever get caught
cheating in class I really didn't end up
telling anybody at school besides like
my clothes
because this is information that you
want to keep concealed at the end of the
day you have to graduate high school
first before you can move on if you go
out there bragging about this stuff and
you know gets caught up in
administration or with the teachers
whatever your friend I recommend all you
guys you know future cheetahs P besides
to do this do that as well I am actually
a little nervous about talking about
this subject right now my teacher that
was in high school she watches a lot of
YouTube so I wouldn't be surprised if
she came across this video right now you
know say so I actually have a little
nervous she was right
I was cheated if you're watching this
right now I just want to say that I am
NOT sorry I have to do what I have to do
okay so can't do anything about it now
[Music]